- THANK YOUSE
FOR MEETING ME HERE.
- OF COURSE, YOU KNOW,
JUST GLAD WE COULD SET
ASIDE OUR DIFFERENCES
AND, YOU KNOW, AVOID A WAR HERE.
- SALUD.
- ALL RIGHT.
SALUD.
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA!
ANTHONY!
NAH, DON'T DO THAT.
WE'RE TRYING TO
AVOID A WAR HERE.
NO, ANTHONY.
NO.
THAT'S TOO MUCH.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WE'RE JUST HAVING A NICE
LITTLE DINNER HERE, ALL RIGHT.
WELL, THAT'S JUST DISRESPECTFUL.
THE--OH, NO, NOT HIS HAIR.
ANTHONY, HE HAD GOOD HAIR.
YEAH, YOU'RE DONE.
YOU ALREADY MESSED THINGS UP.
WHAT IS--WHAT'S GOING--
WHAT ARE YOU DOING NOW?
HIS PHONE?
NO.
OH, NO,
DON'T GO DELETING HIS CONTACTS.
HE'S NOT GOING TO KNOW
WHETHER TO ANSWER IT OR NOT.
YOU FINISHED NOW?
THAT'S--THAT'S GOOD.
LOOK WHAT YOU DID.
NOW, WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF SOMETHING, AND NOW--
WHAT ARE--
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
OH, THAT'S PERMANENT.
THAT'S A PERMANENT
SILLY MUSTACHE.
AH, NOW HE LOOKS LIKE
A SLEEPING MUSKETEER.
THAT'S ADORABLE,
BUT IT'S RIDICULOUS.
HE CAN'T--
HE CAN HARDLY WASH THAT OFF.
WELL, THAT'S--WHERE YOU GOING?
WHAT IS THAT?
NOW WITH THE--
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WHAT ARE YOU PUTTING IN
HIS HAND?
THAT DOESN'T EVEN
MAKE SENSE HERE.
THAT DOESN'T EVEN MAKE SENSE.
OH, OH, ANTHONY!
OH, THAT'S HILARIOUS, BUT SAVE
THAT FOR A SLUMBER PARTY.
ALL RIGHT,
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
OH, YOU'RE REARRANGING
THE SILVERWARE.
THAT'S JUST SO MEAN.
THAT'S--IT'S CONFUSING.
IT'S CONFUSING ENOUGH,
WHAT WITH THE--
ANTHONY.
ANTHONY, DON'T DO IT.
OH, WELL, YOU KNOW, THE SALAD
NEEDED A LITTLE PEPPER,
SO THAT'S GOOD.
SO THAT'S--THAT'S NOT SO BAD.
YOU FINALLY DID
SOMETHING CONSTRUCTIVE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WHAT ARE YOU--OKAY.
YOU'RE PUTTING
THE SILVERWARE BACK.
THAT'S GOOD.
WELL, THAT'S ALL--THAT'S GOOD.
NOW HE KNOWS HE CAN GO
FROM OUTSIDE TO INSIDE.
THAT'S--OH, YOU'RE PUTTING
A LITTLE JUS IN HIS HAIR.
THAT'S GOOD, YEAH, JUS IT.
JUS IT--OH, NOW, WELL, THAT--
IT ACTUALLY LOOKS BETTER
THAN WHEN HE CAME IN.
IF HE WASN'T UNCONSCIOUS
HE COULD GO OUT ON THE TOWN,
SO THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S GOOD.
OH, OKAY, YOU GOT--ALL RIGHT,
WIPE OFF--WIPE OFF HIS FACE.
YEAH, YEAH, AND GET THE MUSTACHE
WHILE YOU'RE AT IT,
'CAUSE THAT'S THE MOST
EMBARRASSING PART.
AH, HE DOESN'T LOOK RIDICULOUS
ANYMORE.
OH, OKAY, YEAH, THAT'S, THAT'S--
NOW YOU'RE HELPING EVERYBODY.
THAT'S GOOD FOR EVERYBODY.
EVERYBODY LIKES THAT.
NOBODY WANTS LETTUCE
ON THE FLOOR.
- SPICK-AND-[bleep]-SPAN.
- ALL RIGHT, WE DONE?
ALL RIGHT,
YOU REALLY TURNED THIS AROUND.
THERE HE--ALL RIGHT,
AND THEN YOU'RE GONE, THEN.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
HE WON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT HIT HIM.
HE WON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT ANY--
OH, NO.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
ANTHONY.
ANTHONY,
I CAN SEE IT IN YOUR EYES.
YOU'RE GOING THE OTHER WAY NOW,
ANTHONY.
ANTHONY, IT WAS GOING SO WELL.
WELL THAT'S--THAT'S--
THAT'S PERVERSE, ANTHONY.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
THAT--WHAT'S THAT?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO
WITH THAT FINGER?
WHAT ARE DOING--OH!
YEAH, NO.
NOT A WET WILLY.
NO!
NO, ANTHONY.
OH, WE'RE GOING TO WAR, ANTHONY.
WE'RE GOING TO WAR.